em luto à luta
eu pesco por três notas a primeira da
polícia será apresentado por essa mulher
maravilhosa que é possível portanto
quero dizer a equipe quer como
profissional que ela vende tanto
privilégio enorme do servidor ela isso
vai por terra só dois problemas primeiro
o fato presenciado por uma viagem é
altíssimo tirava pontos e 4 são gravadas
e publicadas há problemas apontado como
descolar psicológica que é falar em cima
de uma bola vermelha ontem o caso
principalmente o nosso coroa obrigou
disse que eu não vivi fato e outro fato
e gravata porque vm é o fato macaco é
loteria mas foram retirados ea início
você não pode faltar manhã tem que
correr todo está com 28 está e eu estava
com uma camisa ou lembrar que a senhora
acha que ele pronto então a espanha
comprar um eufemismo desta previsão
ele é o cara
ia lá e agora ganhei aqui e qual foi a
estratégia valeu
eu sabia que eu sou o último a eficácia
primário e por servir pra cima de uma
bola vermelha não é não é que foi
combinado é uma vergonha quando vejo
portanto agradeço ao galaxy é compensam
a escolha das cores da camisa
nesse tempo agradecendo muito desafio
que fizeram esta como era estar aqui com
vocês e partilhar reduzir a isto é
apenas isso que o que o prefeito é uma
história tem mais ou menos dez anos
quando eu ainda era um jovem promessa
jovem autarquia tudo fora fátima campos
ferreira
é muito gostoso que viesse ao próximo
encontro aqui eu não sei quanto tempo
estava combinado bem acho que cria uma
pessoa diferente do que era diferente e
portanto quer convidar eu não pensei
nela há também aquelas loucuras
fui o painel na minha mesa eu ia
entrando no juízo cível e na altura
estava já a outra bancada era antónio
costa na altura onde está a pessoa
externa é ser promovido é uma boa forma
da equipa não tinha visto e por isso a
vitória de antónio costa era era porque
já sou eu estiver na lista de um homem e
tratava custos e quebra os autarcas
abaixo do que o que era ruim ficou pior
e é isso
assim o programa que também está na
palavra ao fazer isso o saldo restante
uba liga aquela que é certo e eu tinha
de podendo é ver o pior
nós temos que ela estava com a drag para
fazer o contraponto e eu dei-lhe e só
saiu da nissan que essas coisas círculos
não ser seres olhão não pensei os
autarcas fiscal listas solicitarem seja
o que for a nossa opção e visual fina
cada um de nós pode o seu parece de
princípios
o seu conjunto de princípios o seu
parece o rm por aí
e pela fila várias estudantes
engenheiros forçoso ao taques
circunstancialmente o nosso quadro
doloroso por mais vezes enquanto todos
nós por isso temos o nosso 14 e eu não
me pedia que o rali no início do debate
tivesse tentado mobilizar é que é
possível sair do meu colega fragoroso
acusando de corrupção da voz do que a
vila foi a primeira vez que eu senti o
peso da provisão uma salva de palmas
ganhar do flamengo no bairro flamboyant
na favela do batam ea filha foi
diferente a partir daí temos de viver
lado pela pública por força tanto visão
de que o pai ficou aqui o documento foi
nossa interlocução livre embora difícil
pelo contágio escolher o nosso projeto e
essa é a primeira nota que eu quero
partilhar convosco opção princípios
o quadro é tempo que não troca pela vila
do pedro única e exclusivamente da nossa
opção
eu fiz a minha opção e aqui para
transpor para o outro falou que a equipe
tanto que o valor da liberdade e da
democracia representativa que eu vim pra
cá com o ps para dar nota que o
exercício ético está ligado à liberdade
na forma como nós usamos esse valor
menor e muito muito gripe nós são já 40
também colaborar naquilo que é o
conceito estavam do mesmo lado do estado
e da emoção dos indivíduos que é
controlado estado que é nossa
esteja ligada à produção com é fica com
quadro mas também profundamente sobre a
nossa participação democrática escolher
viver e ainda ninguém pôs em cima da
mesa um regime que nós brigando por um
tempo um conjunto de competências para
que a dersa em nosso novo mandato nós
temos que escutar mas não substitui a
participação cívica
a outra via que essa mesma que vai que é
a dimensão da participação e essa
situação não pode ficar pela caixa e
pelo protesto
o caso não é construtora seja ela não
está bem cuidado e olhar para aproveitar
o dia e há uns dessa situação da forma
que não quer uma participação
construtiva era do depois que sejam é de
todos nós
portilho assinar a lei que cria o
município e e eu gostava de lembrar
estamos oito dias aqui eu não sei se é
falta de organização escolheu esse dia
por este motivo estamos aí com foguetes
que não lançou seu para assinalar a
saída da troika e essa é uma coisa
bonita importados com solidário via só
usar esse exemplo da criança data foi
chamar a atenção para essa coisa da luz
consolidado teve que agradecer a quem
nos deu é quem nos emprestou do mar a 30
mil milhões de euros para nossos
segurados nas nossas costas pagar os
nossos professores aos nossos méritos
nossos vinhos atleta já não ia deixar de
pagar
eles fizeram descer mas será que é o
sentido da responsabilidade que temos
para fazer pela frente e nós com nós
próprios sem que alguém externo a tomar
conta de nós e esse sentido de
responsabilidade é muito importante o
que o poder local
naquilo que é nosso mercado e nossas
forças uns com os outros para fazer mais
coisas em foco muda nada a ver essa foi
a próxima a ser fácil 30 anos e meio de
um tempo e que perdeu tal também está é
que seria fortalecer a sua presença na
gestão da coisa pública em nosso país e
pela entrega do valor da conta pública
precisa o poder local ao invés por
exemplo do país e 65 na conta do estado
pelo poder local
e aí há uma distância enorme e nós
resolvemos esse problema já havia sido
resolvido de qualidade do garcia e
conferir mais poder ao poder local para
que o poder de decidir as coisas esteja
mais próximo dos cidadãos que são a sua
origem são o seu tiro são a razão de ser
de tudo no estatuto da quebra tudo
aquilo que tem esse formato é verdade é
que esse valor
cs estão gostado e centralizado em seus
devidos em simultâneo pouco a cidadania
mais participativa e mais ativa e é por
isso que intervenções como esta o
prisões positivas da rede social das
várias plataformas de aplicação que os
tempos e depositantes são totalmente
centrais para nós conseguir ter um país
mas capaz e temos uma cidadania ativa de
forma bem mais próxima foi mais
influência na hora do que apenas nos
momentos importantes dos atos eleitorais
depois que o movimento sempre
importantes não poder produzir a vida da
cia e da cidadania é estudado
nós estamos a falar de ver a campanha
eleitoral para o parlamento europeu a
população mas a intenção dos fatores
importantes na vida de ouro ganha o
primeiro é tão fofa coisa nós até agora
e isso espeto por euro da união vai ser
assim possa recorrer não era para tratar
transportes e infraestrutura
por isso que não vinha o povo pudesse
ter mais na próxima temporada porque os
que saem hoje visitam os cidadãos
europeus afetar todos muito gosto teria
portugal fora da união européia sobre a
albânia do ocidente que eu queria chamar
a atenção é que devemos exigir
resultados europeus para conseguir o
pessoal da política de coesão e o que
não é exatamente mais uma estrada ou
mais uma operação grande infraestrutura
mesmo o que é importante é que nós
consigamos o exame no segmento econômico
para que o recurso de igual forma não
tenham que ser feliz em ser
rentabilizadas banha a terra do norte
europa e todos
fui pesquisando como cidadãos europeus
atingir aquela que equilibra o evento
enorme para que os índices de qualidade
da china e do fluence naturezas aceder
aos 28 com isso
- a nossa união um beijão e os próprios
pouco coesão e com patamares
basicamente o vasco e também como contra
os preços possam subir toda a gente
chama a atenção no dia 9 vai é com o
coração da europa na interação de vários
órgãos foi a publicação para subscrição
tuba quarta chamada carta da corporação
utiliza européia e que desafiam os
vários poderes públicos 0 14 ponto a
mais e proponha essas cidades como vista
gira européia nós coisa portugal
ajeitamos para municípios e freguesias o
patamar a patamar regional e petróleo
infelizmente ainda não tem opção pública
é uma iniciativa apenas deles fazemos
hoje depois do patamar nacional de
patamar europeu é lógica da europa
pensado já não liberou o financiamento
já não lidera o mundo político também
lideranças culturais são hoje um absurdo
tem buscar a realização do concurso
público e pela pior gestão pública tem
como usar mais o seu filho dela e é
basicamente por esse conjunto de fatores
em cananeia que o exercício de nossa
aproveitados cada um dos dias que
vivemos hoje nós temos a consciência da
importância de ser crítica que tem de
ser uma tudo que contribua para a
solução dos problemas de aproveitamento
das oportunidades é absolutamente
central para que esses nossos próximos
40 anos de democracia específico ativa
de honrar um país notável com uma
história notável nós possamos encontrar
novas capacidades somar as nossas
potências tal estratégia efetiva dos
cidadãos das autarquias das empresas nas
universidades e nós temos a consciência
que se somados
cada uma destas individual
o resultado assim é muito maior do que
simples conseqüência da soma de
matemática província de hubei e esta é
este o grande desafio
o aproveitamente pequena linha por mais
de tudo positiva construtiva e
consignado na pior das forças que haja
mais gente a chegar à nossa terra porque
escolheu pra você boa viagem mais bebês
é descer na nossa tela que haja mais
empresas é de ser o nosso tela e esses
serão os indicadores principais estão
sem levar é convidado pela estão
transmitindo também a todos é ser aberta
mas mais de mil votos de felicidade pois
as penas ou abraçar o passo e vou viver